brian is with us in Sioux Falls South
Dakota hey Brian how are you I'm doing
great Dave how's your day better than I
deserve what's up so I have a question
that's listened for 12 years your
guidance has actually enabled me to ask
I am 26 years old recently invented a
new electrical wall plate for hiding
graduate sensor wires and I'm about to
retire congratulations big dog well done
man that's awesome so so you invented
this thing and you've sold it for a
bazillion dollars so I actually sold it
with a 40,000 mile road trip listening
to your show all the way across the
country for a year just going
door-to-door and it's now nationwide
distributors and it is taking off
running itself okay and so well nothing
runs itself so you built a company or
you've sold the item to a company or
how's it being run so I am still dying
at part-time basically coordinating
voices between my distributors and my
suppliers but my workload has
drastically dropped below the 40-hour
week mark Wow good for you okay and
that's and so I I have no buy of no okay
so what's your question we've done very
very well obviously oh it's all day
because of you ends everything's in cash
flowed you know we're just as a design
here and gettable ill for 20 you know
two thousand dollars for a lawyer for
months I was able to cash flow and just
did that until I got ready to launch but
what that financial guidance has allowed
me to do is I'm still single how do I
approach any eligible girl I meet and
what do I tell her about my income hmm
well I it's interesting because you
don't want to be a target is what you're
saying for the wrong exactly you don't
need a gold-digger we used to call them
in the old days Wow well my son is 25
and he kind of has the same problem
because he's my son right
he didn't have any money because I'm not
dead but
someday he's gonna be in really good
shape you know so you know and he and I
have talked about this a time or two but
it's not ever really been a problem
I think the healthier you are personally
as an emotionally and spiritually the
more normal you are in terms of I don't
mean normal in a bad way but I mean
you're just a regular person but if
you're whole you're not needy
emotionally
you've not got some kind of weird ego
thing going on which I don't hear and
talking to you
you just sound like a guy who came up
with a great I didn't worked his butt
off to me that's what it sounds like and
so just be that guy and you know do you
have any family in your life yep that
one brother and my parents still around
okay cool I would use them as a filter
with young ladies that your that you're
seeing and just to have other people
look over your shoulder in case you've
got a blind spot for one and they see
things and give them permission to speak
to you about it and go you know if you
think somebody's after me for the wrong
reasons speak up okay and go ahead and
just say that out loud
daniel has two sisters and I can promise
you they're filters you can't pass the
sister mafia
your big time you know so that happens
you know and but I think the more hole
you are spiritually the more hole you
are emotionally mental health wise the
more you're going to just naturally
repel those kinds of people I meet for
instance guys who go through a midlife
crisis and you know you know marry the
supposed trophy wife right the second
wife that's after money kind of thing
and most the time it's those guys just
aren't very sure themselves as men and
so they attract they you know they need
they need arm-candy to feel good about
themselves and you're not just don't be
that guy you know you're looking for
someone you're looking for somebody's
beautiful on the inside yes
and by the way it's a plus if they are
on the outside but I mean it's they're
beautiful on the inside and and you're
just gonna take your time and then of
course where you're meeting people
matters because you know we're do
quality people hang out and that's where
you need to be hanging out but as far as
when to disclose the net worth I think
you do that or your income or those
kinds of things the fact that you've
become wealthy later rather than sooner
but certainly you don't want to spring
it on someone but you know after you're
engaged that would be weird
you wouldn't want to do it but but you
know you don't go out the first date and
start spouting off about it you're going
to attract the wrong kind of people
and I would be pretty secretive about it
not we're not in a weird way but I just
wouldn't live a real flashy lifestyle
that that you know Daniel drives a
pickup with about a hundred thousand
miles on it he doesn't he didn't have to
but he grabbed me once dry probably but
he does very well on his own
that's my son as an example so you know
you can just do whatever and that way
you're not putting off signals that that
that that there's wealth here but then
yeah the more serious you get the more
you begin to unpack it and I would just
begin with some other money
conversations and make sure those go
well and that the relationship continues
before I got into that so yeah it's
certainly not a first date thing and
it's certainly long before engagement
but somewhere along though you long
there you just start talking about work
ethic and saving and how they feel about
wealth and how they feel about that kind
of stuff and so now let me ask you this
is is this over ten million dollars so
this has a market potential about 43
million a year that we're currently
extracting only about 1% of so you're
making about Fulani garage doors in the
world so you're making four or five
hundred thousand a year already
yes net yes okay and that's what that
has just started yep so we are I'm very
much in the baby stages where I'm used
to my 80k a year into
sorry I told my friends around me if
you've seen me change yell at me and be
very honest because I don't want to
change from the young conservative
Midwestern Christian that I started with
I don't want to become a different
person just because I now can be yeah
well you need to be a different person
but you don't necessarily need to show
at all yeah you need to be you need to
be capable of managing more and that's
gonna be different you know it's a
different thing making 400 than it is
making a 80 so I well here's the thing I
do not recommend prenups in normal
situations but this is not a normal
situation and so because you're probably
going to have a multi-million dollar net
worth before you're married is what it
sends to me like and then and so you
probably do want a prenup in those cases
are you at least need to consider it and
it's not because she's weird or you're
weird it's because when there's that
much money around weird can just show up
in the form of her mother or her aunt or
something like that you know and then
the influences start moving and it it it
negates their influence when there's a
pre-done agreement now again I don't
believe in prenups in normal situations
but where there's extreme situations I
do recommend them hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]